WHAT HAPPENED
EARLIER LAST YEAR WHEN WE
EXPOSED THE UNMASKINGS THAT
HAD OCCURRED AND WATCHING
HOW THEY OPERATED DURING
THAT TIME PERIOD, I KNEW AS
WE KEPT BUILDING UM TO THIS
BY ALL THE SAME PEOPLE WHO
WERE ATTACKING ME THAT WE
HAD THE STORY NAILED.
THAT WE WERE 100 PERCENT
RIGHT.
AND SO IT MADE IT EASY.
SO, YOU KNOW, I SAID THE
OTHER NIGHT THAT IT’S
ACTUALLY ENJOYABLE BECAUSE
YOU JUST KNOW THAT YOU HAVE
GOT THE STORY.
>> Laura: I ALWAYS LIKE IT
WHEN THE CRITICS COME AFTER
YOU, I ALWAYS WEAR IT AS A
BADGE OF HONOR, ESPECIALLY
CERTAIN CRITICS LIKE THIS.
WATCH.
>>
>> IS IT POSSIBLE THAT THE
REPUBLICAN CHAIRMAN OF THE
HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE HAS
BEEN COMPROMISED BY THE
RUSSIANS?
IS IT POSSIBLE WE ACTUALLY
HAVE A RUSSIAN AGENT RUNNING
THE HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE ON
THE REPUBLICAN SIDE?
>> I HOPE THAT’S NOT THE
CASE AND I CERTAINLY HAVE NO
INFORMATION TO SUGGEST THAT
IT IS.
I THINK THAT.
>> DOESN’T HIS BEHAVIOR
SPEAK OF THAT THOUGH?
I’M NOT THE FIRST PERSON WHO
HAS RAISED THIS.
>> Laura: MARK HALPERIN’S
FORMER WRITING BUDDY.
WHAT ABOUT THESE OUTRAGEOUS
ACCUSATIONS BECAUSE YOU ARE
GETTING HOTTER AND HOTTER
AND HOTTER TO THE TRUTH.
YOU ARE GETTING CLOSER AND
CLOSER AND CLOSER.
>> RIGHT.
>> Laura: THEY ARE TURNING
UP THE HEAT ON YOU AS YOU
ARE GETTING CLOSER TO THE
TRUTH ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED.
>> IT’S SCARY THAT THERE.
WE HAVE BEEN -- REPUBLICANS
FOR A LONG TIME, ESPECIALLY
ON THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE.
WE WERE BEGGING THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THE RUSSIA
PROBLEM AND THEY IGNORED US.
I EVEN SAID IT WAS THE
LARGEST INTELLIGENCE FAILURE
SINCE 9/11.
OUR FAILURE TO UNDERSTAND
PUTIN.
AND, YET, THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA DOESN’T CARE.
YOU THINK THEY WOULD
ACTUALLY CALL OUT SOME OF
THESE GUY WHO SAY THIS STUFF
BUT THE FACTS DON’T GET IN
THE WAY BECAUSE I THINK THEY
DO NOT WANT THIS PRESIDENT
TO BE SUCCESSFUL AND THEY
DON’T WANT REPUBLICANS TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AND THEY HAVE ONE
GOAL IN MIND AND THAT’S JUST
POWER.
THEY WANT REPUBLICANS MOVED
FROM THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
>> Laura: BY ANY MEANS
NECESSARY.
>> WITH POLITICAL DIRT BEING
MOVED FROM A CAMPAIGN BEING
DEVELOPED AND PAID FOR BY A
CAMPAIGN, FUNNELED RIGHT IN
THE FBI TO OPEN UP AN
INVESTIGATION, INTO THE
OTHER CAMPAIGN INTO THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND THEN TO
SPY ON SOMEONE IS SOMETHING
I WOULD NEVER HAVE IMAGINED
THIS IS WHERE -- I KNEW
ABOUT A YEAR AGO, ABOUT LAST
MARCH TIME FRAME THAT THE
DOSSIER WAS USED IN SOME
FORM OR FASHION.
EVEN AT THAT TIME I THOUGHT
TO MYSELF REALLY.
>> Laura: HAS TO BE A MINOR
THING.
>> COULDN’T HAVE BEEN THAT
CRAZY, IT ENDS UP THEY WERE
REALLY THAT CRAZY.
>> Laura: WHAT ABOUT
BRINGING BACK COMEY, MCCABE,
PERHAPS MEMBERS MEMBERS OF
THE STATE DEPARTMENT WHAT WE
LEARNED TONIGHT AND THEIR
INVOLVEMENT IN FILING FOR
THE FISA APPLICATION,
KNOWING WHAT THEY KNEW ABOUT
CHRISTOPHER STEELE EVEN IN
THE SUBSEQUENT APPLICATIONS,
HE WAS UNRELIABLE.
HE HAD BASICALLY ADMITTED AS
SUCH THAT HE WAS GETTING
SUBSOURCED INFORMATION
INCLUDING FROM THROUGHOUT
THE PROCESS THROUGH CLINTON
ASSOCIATES.
ROUX GOING TO BRING PEOPLE
BACK?
>> SO PHASE ONE OF THE
INVESTIGATION WAS FISA
ABUSE, OKAY.
AND WE CLOSED THAT OUT IN
TERMS OF WHAT WE THINK
MEMBERS NEEDED TO KNOW,
WE’RE MOVING ONTO THE STATE
DEPARTMENT AND THE
REGULATORS THERE.
THE NEXT PHASE WILL BE
LOOKING AT ALL THE CAST OF
CHARACTERS AND CONDUCTING
THOSE INTERVIEWS.
>> Laura: STATE DEPARTMENT
THUS FAR, WHAT CAN YOU TELL
US?
>> I CAN JUST TELL YOU THAT
THE STATE DEPARTMENT WAS
GATHERING INFORMATION AND
PASSING TO VERY STRANGE
PLACES THAT SHOULD NOT HAVE
HAPPENED.
>> THE OBAMA STATE
DEPARTMENT.
I WILL SAY COMMENTS OVER THE
WEEKEND FROM PEOPLE WITHIN
THE STATE DEPARTMENT THAT
SAID JOHN KERRY HAD BEEN
BRIEFED ON THE DOSSIER, THEY
PROVIDED THE NEW DOSSIER,
WHATEVER THE NEW DOSSIER IS
AND THEY PROVIDED IT ALSO TO
THE FBI.
SO, BY PEOPLE STARTING TO
TALK ABOUT IT, IT SEEMS TO
ME LIKE SOME PEOPLE MAY BE
TRYING TO DISTANCE
THEMSELVES FROM THE REST OF
THE CAST OF CHARACTERS.
>> Laura: SIDNEY BLUMENTHAL
LONG TIME CLINTON CONFIDENT.
HE WAS TRYING TO PUSH
HILLARY IN EMAILS TO POLICY
TO DUMP QADDAFI, A LOT OF
STUFF GOING ON IN LIBYA
ITSELF.
CODY SHEARER WHO IS A
LONG-TIME CLINTON, YOU KNOW,
HACK WHO WAS -- GOES WAY
BACK TO THE MID 1990S, I WAS
COVERING ALL THIS STUFF BACK
THEN, THERE WAS A SENSE
THOSE TWO WERE INVOLVED AND
PUTTING INFORMATION OUT
THERE THAT GOT IN THE HANDS
OF CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
CAN YOU TELL US ANYTHING
ABOUT THAT?
>> WELL, I HAVE TO TELL YOU
THAT WE HAVE READ A LOT OF
THE STORIES, YOU HAVE TO
WAIT UNTIL WE DECIDE HOW WE
ARE GOING TO PROCEED WITH
THE INVESTIGATION.
THERE IS SEVERAL PEOPLE
INVOLVED.
>> Laura: ADAM SCHIFF GOT
PUNKED.
I THINK WE HAVE THE CALL.
I WANT TO PLAY IT.
>> SHE.COM PRO-MIZEING
MATERIAL ON TRUMP AFTER
THEIR SHORT RELATIONS.
>> OKAY.
AND WHAT’S THE NATURE OF THE
COMPROMISE?
>> WELL, THERE WERE PICTURES
OF NAKED TRUMP.
>> OKAY.
AND OSO PUTIN WAS MADE AWARE
OF THE AVAILABILITY OF THE
COMPROMISING MATERIAL?
>> YES, OF COURSE.
>> OKAY.
WELL, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE WILL BE BACK IN TOUCH
WITH YOU THROUGH OUR STAFF
TO MAKE ARRANGEMENTS TO
OBTAIN THESE MATERIALS FOR
OUR COMMITTEE AND FOR THE
FBI AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
REACHING OUT TO US.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN, IT IS
NOT GOOD ACCENT, RUSSIAN